du schaust dir ab und zu deine fotos von
früher an wie schnell die zeit vergeht
da kommt dann schon mal die frage auf
bin ich noch dieselbe person wie damals
wie kann ich mich selbst bleiben wenn
ich mich doch ständig verändere
zu dieser frage gibt es ein berühmtes
philosophisches gedankenspielen
die geschichte beginnt in griechenland
darf ich vorstellen
das ist theseus ist ein ziemlich
berühmte held der griechischen sagenwelt
und ein begnadeter sie war oft ist der
monatelang unterwegs
trotz heftigen stürmen und wendig zur
manches seeungeheuer
natürlich hinterlassen die turbulenten
reisen auf sie auch ihre spuren
dieser ist muss mit seinem schiff des
öftern aufs trockendock zum meister
seines fachs er ersetzt was es zu
ersetzen gibt ein paar planken sind neu
aber das schiff ist dasselbe schiff
geblieben
es ist fahrtüchtig wie damals
naja nicht lange über die jahre muss am
schiff immer mehr ersetzt werden
irgendwann alles bis auf die letzte
flanke
theseus schiff besteht nun komplett aus
neuen teilen
nach all der veränderung ist das immer
noch dasselbe schiff stell dir vor der
meister seines fachs kommt auf die idee
und baut aus dem alten material das
schiff ihr zusammen gibt es dann theseus
schiff 2 x welches ist das echte das
neue oder das alte das wieder
zusammengebaut wurde
beide oder keines von beiden
bei menschen ist das nicht anders im
laufe der zeit verändert sich unser
körper wie theseus schiff spätestens
nach sieben jahren bestehen wir komplett
aus 19
auch unsere werte ansichten und
interessen haben sich verändert
als kind wollte c't du astronaut werden
und durch all die wiesn
doch geworden bist du angestellte
wir sehen zwar anders aus als früher und
wir denken auch anders aber dennoch gilt
ich bin immer noch der mensch von einst
allen veränderungen zum trotz ich bin
das original was also verleiht uns
unsere identität
deshalb bleiben wir wer wir sind obwohl
wir uns ständig verändern